bonsoir philippe benassaya maire de bois
d'arcy conseiller départemental des
yvelines également vice-président de
l'agglomération versailles grand parc
vous êtes aussi candidat pour la
législative partielle dans la 12e
circonscription des yvelines on en parle
dans un instant un mot déjà de réactions
sur le sujet que l'on vient de voir vous
qui êtes l'un des vice présidents de la
fédération ait l'air dans le département
est-ce que la priorité aujourd'hui comme
ça a été dit c'est reconstruire
reconstruire unis on a pu voir par
exemple valérie pécresse qui a fait
partie des personnes qui ouvrait ce
congrès aa au port marly d'abord c'est
pas donné à tout le monde de faire un
congrès au port-marly de jeunes
républicains de près de 2000 le jeune je
suis pas sûr qu'il y ait cet exemple
ailleurs ça signifie une chose malgré la
reconstruction nécessaire c'est que ce
parti
quoi qu'on en dise contrairement à ce
qu'on entend et contrairement à ce qu'on
lit
c'est un parti qui est bien structuré
bien situé au centre droit et à droite
dans un pays dont le socle est quand
même globalement à droite on l'a vu lors
des dernières municipales
maintenant sous la vème république il
faut toujours qu'ils aient un homme ou
une femme qui représente ses idéaux
présidentielle mais tout ne se passe pas
au tour d'une présidentielle
la vie d'un parti politique c'est des
commissions des rendez-vous des des
présents sur le terrain c'est beaucoup
de choses
maintenant comme je vous le dis si on
doit penser uniquement la présidentielle
il faut reconstruire unis c'est vrai et
je pense qu'on peut en parler on a eu
cette image là puisqu'on avait valérie
pécresse qui est un libre aujourd'hui
qui est plutôt satellite delà des
républicains et puis dont l'accueil a
été plutôt plutôt chaleureux et je pense
que c'est celle à venir à mon avis des
républicains après la reconstruction
parce qu'on a pris quand même une baffe
pardon à l'expression aux européennes on
s'est extrêmement bien ressaisi au
municipal on a gagné beaucoup de villes
de moyenne le nom d'yves à 1030 1000
habitants en france
maintenant c'est la mise en orbite pour
pour pour les présidentielles et je
pense qu'on y va je pense qu'on y va
honnêtement
alors je le disais vous êtes aussi
candidat en ce moment est en campagne
pour la 11e circonscription des yvelines
une législative partielle se profile
premier tour dimanche 20 septembre
prochain on scande
on va voir leur nom s'afficher peut-être
dans un instant sont sur la ligne de
départ une élection je le rappelle rendu
nécessaire après la démission de nadia
qui est entrée au gouvernement comme
ministre délégué à la ville pourquoi
après avoir été maire de bois d'arcy
conseiller départemental des villes
pourquoi cette candidature dans la 11e
circonscription de choses la première je
complète ce que vous venez de dire suite
à la nomination de nadia est commise de
la vie mais surtout son suppléant n'a
pas pu monter pour les faits de les
problèmes de mise en examen
une enquête de me ramène à sa faible
d'internationalisation nationale donc si
le suppléant était monté on n'en
parlerait pas aujourd'hui donc on s'est
retrouvé face à une vacance dans cette
circonscription presque inédite c'est
une situation inédite qu'un député
démissionne pour empêcher son suppléant
de de monter la deuxième chose c'est que
beaucoup plus importante que ce fait
divers malheureux c'est qu'aujourd'hui
je pense qu'en france il faut redonner
la parole aux adducteurs
je pense que la période des députés hors
sol sans ancrage local sans rien je
pense que les français reviennent dessus
je pense honnêtement je le sens je
l'entends j'ai des autres expériences de
terrain est nécessaire pour ce qu'elle
est nécessaire entre nous on n'est pas
forcément fléchi pour des élections
partielles on n'avait pas prévu que
nadia et allait devenir ministre en mai
pour elle mais et que sur ses clients ne
pouvaient pas monter
mais face à cette situation je pense
qu'il faut redonner la parole au terrain
si vous permettez juste une petite
anecdote on l'a vu pendant la crise
sanitaire du coc vide les au printemps
dernier qui était sur terrain et qui a
réussi à obtenir des résultats
tangibles si ce sont les collectivités
locales régions départements et communes
donc je pense que ça les français l'ont
vu il ya un avant et un après qu'ovide
la sueur ça se précise que votre
candidature est sous la bannière la
leyre on est qu'elle est aussi soutenu
par rudy la génération terrain est libre
voilà plusieurs formations de droite et
du centre est-ce que ça a été une
décision difficile à prendre
je demande ça parce qu'il ya la loi sur
le non-cumul des mandats si vous êtes
élu demain député de la 11e
circonscription vous devrez laisser
votre fauteuil de maire est ce que ça
c'est un choix difficile c'est une
extrêmement difficile c'est toujours
difficile et c'est un véritable crève
coeur je le dis puisque c'est dommage
que cette loi ne nous permettent pas de
cumuler député maire d'une ville de 15
mille habitants je vous le dis très très
aisément c'est jouable
peut-être député maire d'une ville de
300000 habitants gipa mais mondeville
tomb raider ci est député je suis
conseiller départemental ça ne pose pas
de d'énormes problèmes
c'est vraiment regrettable maintenant
l'équipe est en place le deuxième mandat
est en place les équipes son faucon
place il n'y a pas de problème mais
c'est vrai que c'est un crève coeur mais
je pense que l'occasion est unique elle
est inédite comme je les dis pour fait
remonter au parlement à l'assemblée
nationale des élus qui obtenait des
résultats sur le terrain et des îles qui
connaissent la réalité qui connaissent
les gens qui connaissent les projets
locaux les acteurs locaux les
entreprises locales c'est important je
pense que le ce qu'on a eu depuis 2007
avec des résultats au pas des résultats
c'est pas mal jugé on fera le bilan de
dudu de ce mandat législatif plus tard
mais c'est vrai qu'on a des députés qui
sont quand même globalement sol qui
connaissent pas trop le terrain il faut
revenir je pense à une organisation
plutôt d'en bas vers le haut et c'est
pour ça que je suis candidat et les
thèmes à apporter à l'assemblée
nationale justement c'est cette
connexion avec le terrain dont vous
parlez avec le terrain qu'à la faire
remonter les bonnes pratiques du terrain
je pense qu'on l'a vu encore une fois
pendant le coc vide
les élus locaux ont de bonnes idées qui
ont été reprises haïr au niveau national
le pouvoir en place un peu négligé au
début les élus terran puis ce sont puis
s'est rendu compte que on obtenait des
résultats est très très remarquable
ensuite il ya je dirais plusieurs
thématiques très importante pour la 11e
circonscription la sécurité l'innovation
parce qu'on
on va reparler du commercial du futur
d'elancourt la vidéoprotection portés
par les collectivités l'environnement
bien sûr l'innovation l'école numérique
et bien sûr je mettrais un dernier thème
la liberté pense que dans notre pays la
liberté est en train de s'éteindre de
plus en plus et il faut des députés des
élus qui redonne cette liberté
d'expression qui est le coeur à mon avis
des valeurs de notre société